his wrestling series dark side of the
ring is back for season three
it debuted on vice tv uh
last thursday it's on every thursday at
9 00 pm eastern time on vice tv
from all elite wrestling our friend
chris jericho is back on the rich eisen
show how are you sir
speaking of favorite guests here i am
[Laughter]
yes here you are i was about to say wait
a minute whenever i ever been a guest on
your podcast even though i keep offering
and you say no problem then don't invite
me
it's okay you keep talking about it it's
weird though because they were like uh
do you want to do a phone or for rich
eyes and like a phoner
wow like usually these days this zoom or
stream or squad cast we're just taking
it right back
to the roots and just doing the phoners
now i like it soon it's just gonna be
notes that we passed to each other chris
that's that's just not good television
it's terrible television but you know
it's all good
um yeah we're gonna when i have you on
the podcast it's gonna be two tin cans
and a string let's do it though
you keep saying that and i'm more than
happy i know i would
i gotta wait for the right for the right
topic rich for these we need something
we can sink our teeth into obviously
your luster's history is one thing but
we need a
some kind of a topic to get into okay we
could do that the fact that i can't
climb the walls of jericho onto your
podcast right now i think i'm stuck in
them right now
kind of you know what i mean like i
think that's my problem but we'll get
through i
promise that before the end of this year
we're going to do a jericho
eisen talk to jericho we're going to do
it in person okay that's what i want to
do
i'm fully vaxxed i'm ready to go chris
whenever you want to do it i'm ready to
go so we can do it perfect
thank you rich so what is the dark side
of the ring chris
walk me through this what is it okay so
this is the series once again you
mentioned that season three and and
much like you know um behind the music
that they used to have on vh1 years ago
there's so many things that happened
kind of behind the scenes in wrestling
not just with the different characters
and and situations and
you know there's there's murders and
there's there's
you know crimes and there's behind the
scenes machinations and all these other
things that
i think people are interested in this
show
whether you're a wrestling fan or not
think about the last dance when
we saw kind of the behind the scenes of
the chicago bulls and this great team
they put together
i am not a basketball fan per se but i
loved watching that documentary yes
because it really gave you a sense of
what it takes to make a successful team
and that's kind of what dark side of the
ring is it's these behind-the-scene
stories that you might not understand
just how hard it is to be in the
wrestling business
and all these different characters that
have kind of been involved and some of
them
have these you know terrible stories and
some of them aren't as terrible but
they're all very very interesting for
sure
so which one's uh one that you're you're
you're proud of bringing
to people's attention or you're you
think well i think last year you know
being a narrator this started with last
year we did two episodes that i think
were really groundbreaking monumental
and one was a story on the chris benoit
tragedy
and how that kind of tied in with the
passing of eddie guerrero
which kind of took chris down this
really dark road
and i got asked to kind of be one of the
the talking heads on it one of the
you know the the experts quote unquote
because these are two of my best friends
yes and as a result they asked me to
narrate it so then i really got into the
whole
series because i could talk about it
from a fan standpoint and also from an
experience level standpoint but
i think the benoit opened up a lot of
eyes to people
um both within the business and outside
who really wanted to get involved with
this
show and then the other one was dealing
with the passing of one heart and the
whole tragedy that happened there which
was
another tragedy but in a completely
different way and that's when we were
able to connect to connect with owen's
family his daughter his son that had
never appeared on camera to talk about
this
and here they are now in the early 20s
so i think once we had those two shows
you're talking you know just incredible
journalism
to deliver these stories and very
riveting sad
tragic um but almost brings a little bit
of closure after you know 20 odd years
of these things happening so
i think that's kind of what really
opened the door to making this such a
successful
series um to this day vice tv's dark
side of the ring again season three
debuted last thursday the next episode
and all episodes are on thursday night
may uh
thursday nights at 9 eastern time on
vice tv and i
you know i know this might be crossing
streams uh between
you know different um circles of
wrestling and certainly different times
did did you see
the documentary the rowdy roddy piper
documentary
uh recently at all speaking of docs on
the subject i haven't seen it yet
because they know
there's a function that i want to check
out i want to see that one i want to see
the steve austin one
so once again very interesting stories
about these iconic characters and you
really don't know
a lot about their personal lives and
what they're like behind the scenes so
i know a lot about roddy's career
because i was there for the
for the last two years of it but i'm
sure it's just learning as well yeah i
mean we were
i mean we we were kind of front and
center the number of texts i got from
people of
his interview when he was here i was the
last person to interview him
wow yeah a week before he passed and it
was um
it was it was an interview that uh i'll
never forget because
it didn't seem like he was all there to
be very honest with you man
i mean yeah well you know what you know
what rich and this is the thing when
you're talking especially those guys
we delve into the season with dark side
talking about the ultimate warrior
dynamite kid
like these are guys if you're talking
about piper and you know savage
all those guys from that era the 80s was
a very tough time in wrestling because
these guys
this is not exaggerated wrestling yes
you're talking about guys that were
definitely on the road
over 300 days out of the year now not
just
what that physical toll is taking the
mental toll being away from a family
being on the road all the
trials and tribulations and and pitfalls
you can fall into
but just think about putting your body
through 300 rats a year and just all
you know if you're talking about the
painkillers if you're talking about like
no wonder those guys are drinking
so much or taking pills and doing all
these drugs because a
just the the travel alone is enough to
wear you down but they're taking all
these bumps as we call them in the
business these falls
i mean it's it's it's just a machine
that basically chewed you up and spit
you out
and you can see that like when you
mention that roddy wasn't all there
he really wasn't i mean you know you
talk to him and he's there but there's a
lot
i think a lot of you know that the the
crafts and brain cells that were left
behind on the road over the years
just by necessity to keep these guys
going and the road is tough man
i mean like because again you know you
gotta you gotta how many days of the
road
are you on the road a year now chris
well now things have changed i mean now
it's all based around television
so aw was always created with the idea
of just doing one show a week
right um but for years in the wwe i was
doing four shows a week every week you
know 52 weeks a year so
times that you know carry the three and
you're talking over 200 225
50 days on the road and that's the thing
too this is not like the nba
where you're picked up and dropped off
and and
you know every travel expense is taken
care of and you you get your plane
ticket
and your itinerary and that's it so
you go to the airport you've got to go
through security you've got to get the
plane you've got to get your bags you've
got to get your rental car you got to
drive to the town
you got to do your show you get back to
the next town find a hotel
hopefully everything isn't sold out and
it is very much
a grind it's very rigorous and all the
stuff you have to go through so that
that takes a toll as well chris jericho
here on the rich eisen show talk is
jericho pod
and of course uh all elite wrestling
here
on the rich eisen show how is that aew
treating you
chris it's been great i mean the thing i
love about aw is it's owned by the khan
family who owns the jacksonville jaguars
and they own the full football club over
in england they treat aw like a pro
sports league and that's the big
difference between the two is that wwe
is
is a wrestling company that comes from
the old school kind of
carney and and and that sort of thing
it's not like that in aw
so we do get treated much more like like
athletes and sports stars and that sort
of thing and then just the fact that
we've come out of the gate
just blew everybody's expectations away
of what uh
what this company could be as far as
television last week
we were the number one most watched show
on cable tv on wednesday night and
that's huge for
for any organization especially for us
we've just been on tv a little bit over
a year so
we've been able to really make a mark
for ourselves by doing things wrong way
and providing something different for
some of the wrestling fans and newbies
who are seeing something going this is
great it's completely opposite of what
we're used to seeing in wrestling and
it's one of the reasons why we've done
so well in just a short time well chris
you know i'm an nfl guy so i clearly
know who the cons are
and what they're all about and it does
appear
um you know that uh somebody who might
be in their employ and under contract to
the jacksonville jaguars very soon
would be tim tebow uh do you think that
maybe you can get tim
involved in an ew get him out there yeah
they're funny because we we've had
kind of a cameo by urban meyer one point
he always talked about tivo and
obviously there's probably a lot of
style there's so much of a spotlight on
jacksonville
and tony kahn who's my boss is very
involved with the jaguars
and i'm sure at some point we'll have
probably canadians from all those guys
and there's no reason not to i mean we
just had a big
storyline like tyson and shaq had his
first match with us
um so we're okay with getting these
mainstream
you know sports you know uh legends and
future legends involved so
i i don't have any uh um doubts that we
will have
but here's the deal chris like let's
let's you and i right now map out
tebow's character and story arc like
let's do it right now
like do we can we turn him into a heel
like terrifying tim or something like
what what what
do you got for me with when you bring
guys like that especially in the city of
jacksonville you know the cons are gonna
be very uh
probably very careful with how you use
them so it's very simple you know
the bad guys running wild this time with
chris jericho and
he he does something dastardly and as
he's
running up the the arena to escape you
know
kibo whips the football at his head
knocks him out the knight catch up to
him and
beat him up and get the big victory
there's a full town anywhere
and tebow throws a football on his head
and knocks them out and i get the win
well here's the deal chris um
the problem is is tebow's trying out to
catch the football
and the reason why he's been gone for
nine years is his
occasional inability to be accurate with
the football so i think we might have to
workshop that a little bit
uh maybe we just make sure it's a taped
match and then we can just edit it out
if it takes a 15
we'll just take the best one
so yeah so you know we we came up with a
a tim tebow is hashtag
all elite um i i don't know if that i
don't know if the the head on his body
right there is the actual
is that all tim tebow that is to all tim
tebow so he's ready to roll
he can pin somebody right now like he
can go top rope
right now chris once again i can't see
the graphic but i'm envisioning it
yes you shared the mind you should uh
look all i know is that if this happens
we'll take ten percent that's all i'm
saying
but i gotta spot probably speak to cody
about that i imagine i'll give you ten
percent
either way i just think it's fair i like
it i like it very much
there you go i like it very much hey man
thanks for the call appreciate it
congrats again on season
three of this show look forward to
seeing more of that um
and anytime you want me chris um i've
i've offered it i really would love to
do it i'd love to
be the a to your q a as opposed to vice
versa anytime
we will do it and we'll do it in person
and i'll make my big return
to the rich eisen shield live in the
studio ratings will go
through the roof i love it we'll be
honest
i look forward to it chris thanks for
the call you be well thanks rich you
guys chris jericho
i am jericho hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here